[Music]
we are now
just about to join nato because we share
common values
we have
interests that we share
and and the finnish people seem to have
come to a conclusion that nato is now
the best guarantee for our national
security we have to build europe as well
as nato
partnerships on values
democracy solidarity that are the core
things that we need to focus on
if it's not only military it is our
everyday life our social security so
that no one is left behind
[Music]
the future of europe conference also
gave us the strong message that citizens
are ready that many actions can be done
on the european level as well we may not
forget that at home also you need to
take care of the people when the rising
energy prices are hitting the poor when
there is industry security european
union can action more so we have to
deliver on every level that's why i
welcome those snde groups to finland
in a crisis like we have in ukraine we
we need a
strong counterforce
and that i see as a historical change
finland is becoming more open to
universalism within the european union